hey guys welcome back to another episode
of the Woodland podcast this episode is
brought to you by Regan Todd at Todd's
racing so go give the leader follow on
his Facebook page for all the latest
news and including probably a sneak peek
at the Waterland horse and also oh
Studio as you're here in this episode
the importance of spending time on your
well-being is massive so here's a
fitting message from the lair Timmy
Bateman hi guys Tim Bateman here from o
studio if you're looking for a unique
experience to gift at Christmas check
out our gethachas at ostudio.co.nz we've
got some awesome packages available that
would be the perfect gift for a loved
one
if you're looking for a career change in
2023 you're passionate about health and
wellness you're a top lead and you have
some money to invest in a business into
your details at
ostudio.co.nz forward slash LED and I'll
give you a shout back to Jimmy
[Music]
uh what a land well for today's episode
we have something a bit different to the
normal we don't have our usual rugby
career to go through but today's guest
has just so much knowledge that I just
want to share with you all how you
breathe can have such a massive effect
on your life whether you're a
pro-sportsman or not I've personally
done a few sessions with them now and I
just want you guys to hear how breathing
properly could potentially change your
life I love picking the brains of a guru
and there is none better than the lad
himself Jamie O'Donnell welcome mate
great to be here mate can't wait to dive
in and have a chat mate like I said I've
done a few sessions with you before and
loved what I got out of them and I sort
of just want to share that knowledge
with all my listeners because I know so
many people are in into rugby or whether
it's Social Sports or professional
sports or even just everyday life I know
how much of a fake breathing can have on
them yeah that's right yeah mate we've
had a few breakfasts and obviously
you've come up home a couple of times
we've been through a few bits so um
there's so much to cover off uh I think
the funny thing with breathing is
something that we do and have done since
we're born and you do it unconsciously
never give any thought to it but you
know you can go a couple of you know 30
days without food or whatever it is a
few days without water and you know
three minutes without oxygen or whatever
so can you hold your breath for three
minutes that's decent I'm thinking like
30 seconds 25 seconds tops yeah I might
have exaggerated
we can do it at the end we'll see who's
got the longest bridge you will win that
for sure but I've come away from a few
of your sessions and you know I've tried
to explain it to other people and then
I've got to the point where I've tried
to explain and I just can't really
articulate what it is or how to actually
do it so um that's why I'm really Keen
to sit down with you and sort of have a
have something I can go back and listen
to and you know have the full effect of
it and be able to really let it sink in
yeah cool I mean I think a good place to
start is probably there's different
elements to it so there's obviously
Sports Performance and breathing within
sport
um and there's the stress response cycle
which is understanding how to perform
under pressure and how to manipulate and
control your breath so that you can
control your physiology and your
psychology in real time very useful in a
sporting environment but also in any
precious situation with the owner
business whether it's corporate whether
it's just family life or whatever I
think that's that's really important but
probably the foundation is actually
coming back to
um looking at your day-to-day breathing
patterns as well so you know know a huge
percentage of the population I think
it's about 65 of the population has got
functional breathing patterns I was
definitely one of those people
um slowly working my way out of it but
um you know from a kid I think I had
asthma and um you know probably over
breathed and mouth breathed my entire
life and wasn't until a few years ago
when I started to dive into the
breathwork side of things through some
health issues actually that I started to
realize how ineffective my breathing was
and then the flow-on effect that in
terms of My overall health and
well-being but also particularly around
mental health and then as you know I've
always been really interested in the
mental side of sport and mental
performance and have sort of spent I
don't know probably a decade
um you know learning in that space and
they'd always sort of been a missing
component to it and it wasn't until I
tapped into the breathwork side of
things and realized
and really understood that trying to
control your psychology without control
your physiology is an incredibly hard or
near-on impossible thing to do so
um yeah it all came for me it all came
back to actually just learning about
day-to-day breathing and
I think assessing you know there's some
really low hanging fruit so just for
anyone listening bear with me for the
next few minutes we'll get some exciting
stuff but you do have to lay a
foundation for it uh the reality is like
how you breathe day to day
um if you're an athlete or
um you know a high performance person
how you breathe unconsciously day to day
does isn't just going to change when you
step into a high performance Arena so
the lowest hanging fruit is to start
looking at your day-to-day General
function of your breathing and I think
for the most part a lot of us
um breathe through our mouth and when
you think about it your nose is here for
a reason you've got two nostrils
um you know there's a whole function in
your nose which moistens the air and
gets everything ready so that you know
you can absorb the air properly and
obviously the size of your nasal
passages are incredibly small compared
to the size of your mouth so the amount
of airflow that you can get through your
nose compared to your mouth differ
massively
um you know a lot of people are walking
around unconsciously breathing into
their opportunity and breathing through
their mouth and probably over breathing
is a thing called chronic
hyperventilation syndrome which is just
essentially over the course of a 24-hour
period where you've got poor breathing
mechanics and you're probably breathing
too fast and breathing too shallow
breathing into your upper chest and
taking in too much ear and so the flow
on effect of that is that essentially
without getting too technical but when
you breathe too much oxygen the flow-on
effect of that is that essentially you
get a you know a reduction in CO2 in
your lungs and in your blood which is
increases your blood pH which then
causes an arousal of the central nervous
system and the flowing effect of that is
that your blood flow constriction you
get reduced blood flow to the brain Into
the Heart your red blood cells and
hemoglobin actually hold on to oxygen
instead of delivering them to your
working muscles tissues themselves so by
over breathing we actually get less
oxygen delivery to the work muscles
tissues itself so if you think about
that in a sports arena that could mean
lower athletic performance potentially
but in a day-to-day life if we're highly
stressed we're in a sympathetic sort of
stress fight or flight State a lot if
we're breathing too much through our
upper chest and through our mouth
um you know that's where over a long
period of time that can lead to you know
chronic illness and things like that as
well so yeah it's not just about sports
performance it's definitely a huge
underlying health element to it
um but I think the the low hanging fruit
is essentially paying attention to how
you breathe throughout the day and it's
something we're unconscious of so if you
just drop in and start paying attention
to the way that you're breathing
um a few times throughout the day and
just try and pick up whether you're
breathing into your mouth or with your
breathing through your nose and then you
know a big one is whether you sleep with
your mouth open and breathe through your
mouth or with your nasal breathing at
night and a Telltale sign that you're a
mouth breather
um would be if you wake up with a dry
mouth in the morning or if you wake up
and you feel like you haven't had sleep
like if you haven't rest rested and
recovered then that could be pointing
towards some dysfunctional breathing
patterns and probably and overuse of the
mouth and under use of the nostrils so
how do you go about changing from a
mouth breather to a nasal breather
because even though I'm now aware that
you're supposed to be breathing through
the through the nasals I've been waking
up with the dry mouth now and again
Panic shut my mouth and you know try and
get get it back through the nose but how
do you make that big shift uh the lowest
hanging fruit is simply to tape your
mouth at night and I know it sounds
pretty wacky and out the gates but um
yeah like I'm someone who's breathed
through my mouth for the majority of my
life uh particularly at night and woken
up dry mouth in the morning uh often
woken up after an eight or ten hour
sleep and felt like I hadn't slept at
all you know wake up foggy in the
morning
and so probably a year and a half two
years ago I started simply just taking
my mouth shut right um read it read a
book breathe
um which went into some of it and
decided to give it a try and noticed a
pretty instant change
um in terms of how I felt in the morning
uh it's like I'm not going to say it's
an instant change because it's pretty
unnatural if you breathe through your
mouth for your whole life to then just
switch so um don't go and tape your
whole mouth shut you can just get a
little strip of medical tape and put it
over your mouth here so that you can
still you know take care and through
your mouth if you needed to yeah um but
it just helps close the lips at night
and helps to retrain your body to start
naturally breathing in through the
nostrils and out through the mouth
um a lot of people will say that they
don't breathe through their nose because
they have congestion in the Airways but
you'll notice that the more that you
start to breathe through your nose
unless you've got like a an obstruction
but most people who experience
congestion in the Airways it's actually
because they're not using their nose
enough so when that's not used it gets
inflamed causes constriction and so once
you actually start breathing through the
nose you'll find it easier and easier
true but the bottom line is you've got
to start and I think the first thing is
just paying attention to it
understanding it
um and starting to shift towards uh an
awareness throughout the day whether
it's just setting little timers a couple
of timers throughout the day just to
check in on your breath and you know
that awareness is the first step
um and then the second thing would be to
you know if you do find yourself waking
up with a dry mouth or you'll find
yourself
um you know that you know that you are a
mouth breather then uh to take them out
at night and give it a crack and um you
know see how you feel after a few weeks
mate that's me tonight so do you never
have anything in your like anything
abstracting your nose I always feel like
I have something like in or floating
around my nose but there's always
something in there that's sort of
abstracting my breathing at least a
little bit totally yeah I think most of
my life I genuinely believe that I had
to have surgery on my nose uh like I
thought you know that when we can get
the sinuses brought out
um yeah I genuinely thought that I
needed to get that surgery done and I'd
actually been to a nose ear and throat
specialist and
um yeah since retraining my breathing
patterns
um
like I'm doing me wrong I'll still have
times where
um there's a bit of congestion and
things there but for the most part my
Airways the capacity and the ability to
have clear unobstructed breathing is
completely different to what it was a
couple of years ago and that's just from
actually training myself to use in those
right it's so interesting and you
mentioned like what what are the other
benefits you've found from breathing
through your nose yeah the biggest one
for me changing your breathing rate so
obviously when you change you when you
start breathing from your mouth well
you're probably quite got a quite a fast
breathing rate breathing into your upper
chest
um whereas when you start breathing
through your nose and start training
yourself to breathe properly
you can slow your breathing rate down
um and slowing your breathing rate down
has obviously well it has a huge impact
um on whether you're pushing towards a
sympathetic stress state or whether
you're in a more relaxed calm risk and
digest State um parasympathetic State
and I think looking back on it now uh
having chronically mouth breathed
um as a youngster and then you know
playing Sport and everything else
sleeping with my mouth open and then the
day-to-day stress of life and running a
business and um you know the busy
Lifestyles that we all live pressures of
General Life probably found that over
the years I was you know really stuck in
like a stressed State more often than I
needed to be and so I think probably the
biggest thing for me is through
re-educating myself on how to breathe
properly and changing my breathing
patterns back to nasal breathing is the
biggest thing for me has been mental
um you know being able to control any
kind of underlying anxiety and just
having better control of my mental state
feeling calmer and spending more time
um balance either you know balancing
that nervous system better or being uh
able to push towards a parasympathetic
risk and digestive State as opposed to
just constantly being stuck in a stress
State and what pushed yeah um to get
sort of into breathing or look into it a
little bit deeper like you mentioned the
house air was was that what really made
you want to go deeper into the space
yeah it was I a couple years ago like I
was having some gut issues yeah and I've
always been like super healthy person
never really had any um you know any
illnesses or anything like that have
never had to deal with any medical stuff
um but started to just have gut issues
uh had some skin flare-ups and ended up
with like a skin infection
um and essentially to cut a long story
short I got some tests done privately
through a nutritionist in Auckland Katie
Boyd and um there were some things out
of whack with the gut but uh the biggest
one was there was a positive cancer
marker for stomach tumors or colon
cancer and yeah so quite out of the out
of the gates and I got that test result
the day before we went into lockdown
um and so yeah so literally got the test
back and it said the I think the
acceptable Market was like a 3.5 or a
four and I was at a 10.1 or a 10.3
um and Katie said to me you need to go
and get a colonoscopy and like chip and
like immediately and then we went into
lockdown and you couldn't access health
or medical help for three or four months
I can't remember how long the first one
was but it was a while all right stress
levels through the road yeah and so I
sort of like oh [ __ ] what do I you know
what am I going to do
um and just figured that I could spend
three you know however many months we're
going to be in lockdown worrying about
it and making the whole situation worse
knew there was a correlation between
disease and stress
um and so decided that one thing that I
could do would was just take control of
my stress levels throughout that time
make sure that I was managing my stress
um because I didn't want to exacerbate
anything that was there potentially and
so I started doing research got into
cold plunging
um I'd already been doing a bit of that
stuff previously but really started to
look into it and really tapped into the
breath work side of things through that
and
um it's funny because looking back
knowing what I know now being in that
stress State you know constantly and
inefficiency with my breathing probably
led over years to less blood flow to the
digestive system over time so not saying
that that was the reason but it would
have been a contributing Factor probably
and then you know the flow on effect of
trying to push through and build
businesses and constantly on the go and
never never learning to down regulate
um and go into that recent digest State
properly so that was the reason that I
got into it and really started taking it
seriously and then the more I started to
study it the more I started to see the
applications towards Sport and towards
General Health General Life
um winning did some courses with some
great people like Dave Wood who's up in
Auckland
um what is awesome and obviously he
works with some pretty high level people
he was a
yeah a paramedic for 13 years so he's
got a background in this stuff he'd
actually had some gut stuff as well so I
started talking to him about that and he
said mate I've been there and all about
it
um just tap in and just keep going down
the road you're going with the breath
work
um
and
um yeah it was through doing his stuff
and keeping in touch with him um it
really pushed me to start doing some
actual like training and get a
certification and
um you know start working in the space
so that that was that was the Catalyst
for it it was definitely Health
um turned out that everything was fine I
did have some cancerous polyps but they
were removed before it was a problem so
um yeah it's funny because you look back
on it and sometimes the worst things
that happen to you turn out to be the
best things and I've thought about this
quite a lot recently where had I have
never had those Health scares and things
um I would never have been introduced to
the world which I'm really passionate
about now so it's funny how that that
sort of happened so it is a like
everything like they say everything
happens for a reason and that's that's
another really cool example of it yeah
we Health scare pushes you down this
route and look at you now you're you're
a breathing Guru yeah it also just made
like I think the health thing made me
think about controlling stress mentally
so I'd always tried to uh I always
thought that I I genuinely didn't think
I had mistress I think that was the
thing I thought that was bulletproof
um had always been really interested in
mindset and positive psychology and
things and so I'd always built a really
good perspective or what I thought was a
really good perspective uh and had
always managed to kind of Thrive under
adverse situations and almost liked
pressure and you know all that so I kind
of loaded my plate as much as I could
and I thought that that was how I got
the best out of myself
um and I genuinely didn't think that I
had much stress because mentally I was
fine but the stress was manifesting
itself physically in my body and
um yeah I guess that was a wake-up call
for me where I'm like it's not just
about the mentor it's also like there's
the physical there's this physiology and
the psychology and the crossover which
is called um psychophysiology but
um those two things can't sort of
coexist without each other and
um I guess it was learning that through
my health
um but then also looking at it from a
sports performance perspective and going
oh hang on how does it Supply to things
like you know sports psychology is
massive but it's all about the mindset
and it's all about you know creating a
high performance psychology but how much
are we teaching about controlling
physiology and down regulating your
physiology
um so that you can have a clear Calm
Mind under pressure and so um yeah it
was through the health that I started to
put those pieces of the puzzle together
and then it all became pretty obvious
and there's some other people out there
who are doing great work like Nigel
Beech who's another guy in New Zealand
who's doing some great stuff
um listened to a few of his talks and
things and um
you know he was talking about that
crossover and um you know particularly
within sport the ability to control your
psychology
um you know being largely reliant on
your ability to control your physiology
so a few few good people started talking
about it and then started listening and
studying it more and
um yeah as you know we've had some
pretty good conversations about it so
that's so cool so what's everyday sort
of breathing look like for you what's it
what's your breathing routine obviously
you take your mouth at night and wake up
feeling fresh but then then what's the
rest of the day look like uh I just I've
got a like a 20 it's about a 21 minute
breathing flow that I do every day it's
just Cadence breathing and the entire
purpose of it is to put me into as much
of a relaxed
um parasympathetic State as possible so
for anyone that's listening you've got a
sympathetic nervous system and you've
got two branches of sympathetic nervous
system the um sympathetic nervous system
and the parasympathetic nervous system
and the sympathetic nervous system is
your stressed vital flight
um or free state
um typically referred to people probably
familiar with that term vital flight
State and then you've got your
parasympathetic branch which is your
rest and digest relaxed State
and so the breathing flow that I do has
got three different cadences to it but
it's all about slowing the breath down
and achieving light slow deep breathing
nasal breathing and yeah stimulating the
vagus nerve and really putting yourself
into a relaxed calm state so I do that
every day that's sort of been religious
for quite a while now like up they're
brushing my teeth they're just dropping
into it
um obviously we've done it together you
feel great at the end of it and there's
multiple reasons to that to do that
daily practice but for me number one is
to balance the nervous system make sure
that I'm down regulating and bringing
myself back to that calm relaxed
parasympathetic rest and digest State
because the reality is like life
stressful there's [ __ ] that's going to
come at us left right and Center if you
want to go and build a business or coach
a football team or do anything great
um you're going to have to learn to
endure greater levels of stress so it's
not about trying to get away from stress
I think sometimes when we talk about
stress it's framed up really badly as if
it's a bad thing
but the reality is like if you want to
do anything great in life you're going
to have to be able to be resilient and
you're going to have to be able to cope
and deal with a large amount of stress
and so it's not about pushing it away
it's about learning to embrace it and
learning to function with it but not
allowing that chronic underlying stress
to build up and so for me the daily
practice is about making sure that I
bring myself back down every day and
down regulate the system and also you
know throughout that 20 minutes you're
also training your breathing capacity as
well so you're strengthening your
breathing muscles you're using proper
technique because I think that's one of
the big things like
um especially when you're starting out
most people's or a lot of people's
breathing mechanics are quite poor we've
always breathed into the upper chest and
use the chest muscles to breathe but
we've never actually breathe into the
diaphragm and use your proper breathing
muscles so often when you make that
transition towards that low slow deep
breathing it's quite hard to achieve and
that's purely because the breathing
muscles are so weak and so slowing your
breath and softening your breath right
down can be quite challenging from a
mechanical perspective
and so that daily breathing flow is a
good way to strengthen those muscles as
well and then the stronger the muscles
the more reps that you put into the bank
and the easier it is to breathe properly
without thinking about it so
um yeah I do my daily breathing flow and
then if I'm doing any exercise like if
I'm doing any cardio work try and nasal
breathe as much as possible throughout
the cardio so if it's on the assault
bike or going for a run or whatever it
is even if you just go for a walk I'm
trying to be really conscious of
breathing through my nose not through my
mouth because my natural tendency is to
rock back to the mouth and particularly
under stress like on you know exercise
yeah
um and like I've always been putting
into my Combat Sports and boxing and
bits and pieces and had really poor
breathing really poor breathing in
general uh when under stress and when
exercising and so a big transition for
me has been to bring back and really
ingrain those good breathing patterns
not just day to day but to bring them
into an environment where you are
stressed and under pressure as well
um and there's huge benefits to using
nasal breathing when you're doing
exercise as well um increase your CO2
tolerance
um which helps with your kind of
athletic endurance and things as well
um so there's a raft of benefits that
come with nasal breathing during
exercise but it's definitely one of the
lowest hanging fruits in terms of
um improving your breathing mechanics
and your mind muscle connection for
breath as well because a lot of the time
when you're exercising uh there's a lot
of air hunger and you feel like you need
to take in a lot of oxygen so naturally
you open your mouth and you're taking in
these huge big ineffective breaths into
your upper chest but you're not actually
really you're often just breathing into
dead space and not really breathing it
into your lungs and you're actually
probably getting poor oxygen delivery to
the working muscles and cells because
you're you're over breathing
um and yeah not breathing efficiently so
nasal breathing through exercises is a
great one try and do that as often as I
can whenever I'm doing any cardio stuff
yeah and that's it as far as breathing
goes it's basically my 20 minute routine
and then just in the exercise making
sure I'm nasal breathing yeah so so what
intensity is can you train up to and
still breathe through your knees I
always found like as soon as it got a
little bit hard I'm straight into the
mouth trying to get it as I can and
effectively but if I try and stab my
nasals I feel like I'm running out of
air yeah that's right
um well for a start as soon as you as
you switch to nasal breathing you're
taking in this oxygen right so um you're
going to have a build up of CO2
um so you've got yeah oxygen and CO2
um always balancing your biochemistry
when you're breathing so
um when you switch to nasal breathing
from mouth breathing particularly during
exercise you'll be taking in less oxygen
or you'll be taking at least a year
obviously and you have CO2 build up
particularly if the muscles are working
and producing CO2 and if you're
breathing through your nose and not
breathing through your mouth like when
you breathe out through your mouth you
dump CO2 out so you lower that CO2 level
so naturally when you shift and and
switch over
um well until your body adapts you
probably have a higher level of oxygen
hunger initially and it's a bit of a
mental battle where you've got to learn
to control and understand that you don't
necessarily actually need more oxygen
it's just that CO2 is the trigger that
tells your brain that you need to
breathe so if you've got CO2 building up
in your system it's telling your brain
that you need to breathe
um but it's not actually that you're
deprived of oxygen it's just that you're
getting that trigger to tell you to
breathe so it's a bit of a mental battle
that goes on which I think you have to
fall in love with initially when you're
trying to make that transition but yeah
also if you haven't breathed through
your nose before like if you're just
transitioning straight away you're not
going to perfect it straight away I
think I use the analogy with you you
know if you walk into the gym the first
time and expect to pick up a 300 kilo
weight on the deadlift you're probably
not going to be able to you'll be shaky
and you'll be ineffective and then you
know the more repetitions and the more
technique that you practice uh you know
all of a sudden you start to build up
your strength and over time you can
reach those that capacity and it's
exactly the same with breathing like if
you just switch into it today and you've
never ever trained your breathing
muscles you've never ever
um you know trading that capacity uh and
you've never been used to the feeling of
oxygen hunger or um you know using your
nose nasal passage you're not going to
get it in day one it's about
understanding the benefits of it and
then committing to a protocol and a
training routine just like you do with
anything else and starting to implement
it into your day-to-day life and then
the more that you train it the more
repetitions that you get in the bank the
more you strengthen the breathing
muscles and increase your breathing
capacity
um then the easier it all becomes and
obviously there's a lot of guys who are
about to embark on a pretty tough
pre-season give us a like a real like
example of like a yo-yo test where they
they they run for 20 meters come back I
get that 10 second rest what does this
sort of breathing look like in that to
help someone out so PB should probably
ask you you're the yo-yo King aren't you
um there's actually been some quite
interesting studies like there was a
study down in the UK
um was actually used professional rugby
players doing a test testing their
repeat Sprint ability yeah so
essentially that was be similar to a
beat disc but it was done over 40 meter
Sprints and I think it was pre-season
but they took 21 professional National
level rugby players in the UK yeah split
them into two groups and they did a
four-week training block where one group
they increased their cardio sessions by
two sessions per week and the other
group they I think they reduced them by
two and then they added breath hold
Sprint work
um and they tested the group at the
beginning across the group and the
average repeat Sprint ability over a 40
meter sprint was 9.1 so the average of
the group they could Sprint 40 meter
Sprints continuously so 40 meters rent
back to the Mark I think it was a 22nd
break 40 minutes rent back to the mark
40 meter sprint and the average was 9.1
and after four weeks the group who did
the extra cardio sessions went from 9.1
to 9.8 and the group that did the breath
hold Sprint training but reduced cardio
training went from 9.1 to 14.9
um so I don't know we're looking at like
what a 40 odd percent increase in
overall athletic performance
um within like a four week block so yeah
I mean it sounds too good to be true
when you say it like that um but yeah
that was one of the studies that they
did the way that you do that is you
breathe in through your nose out through
your nose pinch and hold your nose and
then do the Sprint on a breath hold at
the bottom of the breath hold so after
the exhale yeah uh and then what you're
doing there is obviously you're not
breathing so your carbon dioxide levels
are building up as you're sprinting so
you're going to get to a you know a
pretty high level of your hunger pretty
quickly which forces your body to adapt
so when your body starts to adapt and
change its sensitivity to carbon dioxide
it means you can start to handle higher
levels of carbon dioxide means you need
to breathe less so everything becomes
more efficient you're also getting an
increase in oxygen delivery to the
working muscles and cells because when
you've got increased carbon dioxide in
the blood and in the lungs it helps the
hemoglobin or the hemoglobin ends up
releasing more oxygen to the working
muscles themselves so
yeah and in short funnily enough uh you
know essentially breathing less actually
creates more oxygen delivery to the
working muscles tissues and cells and
over breathing uh can you know create
less so
um yeah it's interesting going into
pre-season and things like that there's
lots of techniques um that teams are
using and individuals are using around
breath hold work and um you know the
simulation of altitude training
um that would be one aspect of it the
other aspect of it is
um you know training yourself to have
proper breathing mechanics so that you
can
um use nasal breathing to soften
um lighten and slow down your breathing
when you're under load so like let's say
you do have a uh like a fast passage of
play where you're running consistently
um you're heading racks
you know maybe there's 20 phases or
something like that and by the time you
get to the end of that the whistle goes
and you might have 30 seconds or 20
seconds where you've got to get your
head together and recover
um so you know it becomes incredibly
important around the recovery aspect as
well and I know that that's talked about
a lot within professional sport these
days it's the importance of recovery but
your ability to recover fast in real
time essentially comes down to your
ability to control your breath and down
regulate your system in real time so you
know if you're training uh yourself day
to day to have better breathing
efficiency better breathing capacity
um and and you're training your ability
to handle uh higher levels of CO2
um then you know your ability to recover
in real time is going to be a lot
quicker than other guys as well which
means that you can get up and go again
um you know after that next set piece or
whatever it is so there's there's that
from an athletic perspective but there's
also the mental side of that as well
because obviously if you're breathing
um incredibly fast and hard and into
your upper gesture activating a stress
response as well which means that your
body is going into an upregulation and
that's when it's very hard to control
your mind and become under pressure as
well or calm in that moment you can't
really be calm and creative in your
thinking when your body's in a stressed
State
um and so those guys who can recover
quicker and down regulate
um by controlling their breath uh you
know will also have an increase in terms
of their cognitive ability and their
ability to control and have a calm mind
when it matters most so that's obviously
a huge part of professional sport
particularly when you reach the you know
the top levels because everyone's on a
similar level when it comes to athletic
ability and
um you know skill set it's pretty even
across the board there's a few freaks
out there but most people are pretty
even and really what separates guys is
their ability to perform weird at
manners and when the pressure's on and
to consistently focus and perform under
pressure and um you know a large part of
that comes back to your ability to
control your breath and down down
regulating control your physiology so
that you can control your psychology and
that's massive in rugby a like instantly
think about all the stoppages that there
is like obviously when you're when the
ball's in play it's pretty intense like
especially when you're hitting those
racks or getting through some physical
contact but and there's a lot of
downtime especially in the backs where
you've got these scrum resets and times
to get set in the line out and things
like that lots of opportunities to like
you say get your breath working
um have this opportunity to recover and
be ready for that next
um phase I think that's right I think
Rugby's like you know combat a sport
you've got no time yeah you get a minute
you get my five to five minute round or
a three minute round and then you've got
a one minute break to recover
um and but you're you're on for that
five minutes and you don't really get
much within that five minute passage
where you're allowed to relax
um whereas rugby I think we worked out
that there's roughly 30 minutes ball and
play yeah uh over an 80 minute game so
essentially you've got 50 minutes of
time where you can be regulating
um down regulating your system calming
your breathing and getting ready to make
sure that you're ready to rock and roll
mentally and physically for that next
play but the majority of that 50 minutes
is
um you know not by everyone but I'd say
for the vast majority is pretty
ineffectively used
um even when you're talking about
players or when it's coming to key
moments in the game like when you're
games on the line and you're walking
into the the key line outs and
um you know scrummages and maybe you've
got a couple of minutes where you've got
to try and get a try and get the game
off the other team
um those conversations that you're
having and those decisions that you're
making require you to be calm and
collected
um in prison and if you're
not recovered properly and your
breathing is really inefficient and
you're in a stressed uh sympathetic
State and then you're trying to make
those decisions and communicate to your
teammates and things you're going to be
less effective in those moments and
obviously that's where games and want to
loss yeah one or loss so
um you know I know Gary Evans obviously
um you know is pretty famous for
creating the red blue system which the
All Blacks used and you know that's the
same thing that's that parasympathetic
sympathetic and understanding where
you're at and so yeah it's about using
your breath to be able to control and
down regulate in those times so that
you're you're sharp and Lucid in
creative and clear when you need to be
so what does that breathing look like
for for someone like there's there's
been a long phase your knackered what
does that breathing look like for that
next 30 40 seconds that you've got for a
start you probably need to understand
just we'll just rewind a little bit
because you probably need to understand
for anyone who's listening like what
that stress response cycle is and what's
actually happening there so
essentially like when you when you're
under stress whether that's physical
stress uh like you know maybe you've
just been having rocks and you're you're
in a really upregulated State
um breathing into your upper chest and
you're breathing fast and you're
breathing hard
um or you know whether you get a fright
like you know if someone cuts you off at
an insection and you hit the brakes and
like that initial response is like a
like you get a fright whether you're
hopping cold water and you get it right
or with their psychological as well like
it can happen through thinking like you
it might be before a game where you're
thinking and you stand to get stressed
at the thought of um you know maybe
performance anxiety or
um whatever it is but whatever the
stressor is
um as soon as you create a stress
response in the body the body releases
adrenaline and cortisol which is the
stress hormone um and what adrenaline
cortisol does or adrenaline
um it creates an up regulation in your
physiology so your breathing rate starts
to increase your heart rate starts to
increase your blood pressure will
increase your skeletal muscle
flow blood flow will change so you'll
start pushing your body will start
pushing blood flow to the extremity so
that you can fight and run
um and when your body's in that kind of
upregulation then your mind starts to
upregulate as well that's when your mind
starts to get busy and you get a lot of
chatter and things aren't necessarily
clear you can become panicky which
creates more stress which drops more
adrenaline which upreculates the body
more and that's that's stress it's a
very simple explanation of that stress
cycle and so that can be physical that
can be through
um you know training and being in a game
environment but that can also be mental
from thinking like if I said do you if I
put a stressful situation in front of
you now and said that you know for
example your family have been kidnapped
or something like that the thought of
that would create that stress response
you'd get that up regulation and then
your mind would start to go crazy and
you probably wouldn't be that rational
which would create more stress up
regulate the physiology more um and that
you know an extreme example of that is
probably in you know heading towards
anxiety or a panic attack
um but and once you understand that
cycle you can understand where you need
to intercept it and the only way that
you can intercept it is through breath
uh and so right at the very beginning if
you when you
breathe instead of taking in and taking
a short shallow fast breath you know
like if I gave you a fright right now
you're gonna
you know you suck in through your mouth
straight away because the body's natural
um responses to get oxygen so that you
can fight and run do whatever it's
setting the system to be in the um in a
fight or flight State
um but if you can control your breathing
right at the beginning of that by going
to a light slow deep breathing
um and really slowing down and softening
your breath then you have the oh you can
have the opposite of that entire cycle
which is where you can stimulate your
vagus nerve through light slow deep
breathing which releases acetricaline
which is your um the hormone which is a
relaxant so uh when a citric colons
released it slows the heart rate I mean
the heart rate is slowed it makes the
brain interpret that the body's safe and
puts you into that more into that
resting digestive state so essentially
what we're trying to do is uh control
those two cycles you're either in one
you're in either an up regulation cycle
or you're putting yourself into a down
regulation cycle
and so
um in in a match
um you know if you've been running
around the pressures on uh you will be
into an upregulated State a lot of the
time and you need to be into an
upregulated State because an upregulated
state is good a lot of you know
sometimes but you just don't want to
stay there necessarily or you want to
have control of when you are there and
when you're coming back to a more
relaxed state
um and so an example of it in real time
would be if you've just hit phase after
phase after phase
um maybe it's been up and down the field
and you're really blowing and the
whistle goes the first thing to do would
be to breathe take a big breath in
through your nose slow big inhale
through your nose and your natural thing
is that you're going to want to breathe
through your mouth straight away but if
you're training nasal breathing and
you've got a good breathing capacity
good breathing mechanics
um
and if your biochemistry has been
improved through doing the the nasal
breathing over time and the different
protocols then you know breathing in
through your nose taking your breath in
through your nose and then probably for
the first couple of breaths dumping all
the oxygen out through your mouth as
quickly as you can so if you've been in
a really fast passage of play time and
time again you've probably got a high
level of carbon dioxide and so you'll be
wanting you'll be you'll have like an
air hunger where you really need to
breathe so the first thing that you want
to do so that you can slow and calm your
breathing down is to dump that CO2 out
of your system the best way to do that
is to take a big breath in through your
nose and then just really like
push it out through your mouth
slow inhale through your nose
really push it out elongate it and push
it out through your mouth and by doing
that and two or three of those breaths
you will reduce your level of carbon
dioxide pretty quickly and that should
enable you to drop back into a slower
lighter nasal breathe breath
um so yeah if you're going from
Passenger play to passenger to play then
the whistle went the first thing
breathing through the nose dump it out
through the mouth and through the nose
dump it out through the mouth and then
try and find a really calm gentle Rhythm
after that of nasal breathing where
you're slowing down your inhale and
really elongating your exhale and just
trying to slow and bring your system
right back down and you should you know
particularly with breath work training
you should be able to achieve that
pretty quickly right I'm coming out of
retirement
and read it and and the key the key is
obviously to train it right like
um the key is not to get into a game and
try and do it the key is that you're
going into pre-season or whatever now or
just in general when you're in the gym
or you're out for a run is to try and
put yourself in that state where you
we've got extremia anger and you're
really blowing and then to see how well
you can control your breath straight
away and probably be pretty ineffective
initially but as you start to train it
um you know your capacity and your
ability to do that will increase yeah
obviously when you're um when you've got
time in a game to recover
and you've got that chance to slow it
all down but what about when you're
actually working like
um you're in like a Bronco test or
something how how are you supposed to
breathe in those sort of things where
it's like there's no rest for you to try
and down regulate your breath yeah
that's a good question
um again like you'll you should be able
to con like if you've built up your
tolerance and your capacity and your
mechanics you should be able to for at
least a decent percentage of that
control yourself through a nasal
breathing
um but the reality is like when you're
if you're at 100 output or a really high
output then there's going to be a need
at some point where you can switch over
to mouth breathing
um the when it comes to something like a
Bronco it's probably about the pre the
training that you've done previously and
also you know there's lots of stuff
there's so many different techniques and
ways that you can manipulate your breath
um even in terms of warm-ups and things
like that so things that you can do from
a warm-up perspective using breath holds
um to kind of get your body to adapt
that higher level of CO2
and you know increase its efficiency so
so there's certain breath hold drills
that you can do in a warm-up before a
Bronco which might help throughout the
Bronco but I think the main thing is is
training your mental ability to stay
calm and relaxed in your breath when
you're under stress I think that's
that's the bottom line the reality is
like we're it's breathing is such an
automatic thing
um and the Brain sends signals to tell
you when you need to breathe and we've
only ever paid attention to those so
it's quite unnatural to start overriding
that and pushing against some of that
and fighting some of your hunger and
things like that but the reality is
um
you know the the more that you can stay
nasal breathing and to a light slow deep
proper mechanics
um under stress then you know the better
your overall performance is going to be
the calmer you're going to be in the
moment so the trick really is is just to
try and master that and build up that
capacity over time
um you know you take Israel adisanya for
example uh you know most Combat Sports
athletes are breathing out their mouth
within a couple of minutes
um and that's just purely because they
haven't really they paid a lot of
attention to their cardiovascular
training not necessarily a lot of
attention to their breathing training
um whereas Israel's been working with
Dave obviously for uh 18 24 months now
um and you know for most of Israel's
last two or three four fights he's
barely taking their breath through the
mouth in an entire five minute round
five five around five five minute rounds
um you know his nasal breath is entire
way through and his wrist periods and
when he's standing and striking with
someone
and you know that gives him the ability
to be incredibly calm and focused and
present in the moment because he's not
um you know breathing erratically and
he's he's uh down regulating it
essentially down regulating a system and
enabling himself to stay calm and
creative
um despite being in a combat situation
so you know he's a good example of it
um you know there might be times within
those fights where there's huge
exchanges and you know potentially you
have to go to mouth breathing before you
can switch back to nasal breathing I
think he's been pretty consistent
through his nose just about you know
every breath of every round of every
fight recently
um but you know that's a good example
because he's under extreme pressure and
he's probably physically pretty
exhausted in there as well but he's
trained himself mentally to be able to
stay
um you know to good breathing mechanics
and to be able to stay calm in the
moment that's a really cool example
because I remember doing some boxing
sessions you know in like the
pre-seasons when you have to go 60
seconds on with body punches and stuff
and these used to erect me obviously
when I was boxing I was never breathing
I was pretty much holding my breath when
I was punching and then I was gasping
for air through my mouth when I wasn't
and I was always wrecked after a boxing
session compare it to a running one
where I was probably more naturally
better at breathing for some reason but
yeah I felt like I could run for a long
time without being as tired as if I went
for one minute of boxing pretty much
because probably my breathing was so
erratic yeah totally all we knew boxing
as well you're using a lot of your chest
muscles so you're probably double
draining those muscles like if you're
breathing with your chest muscles and
then boxing with your chest muscles and
your upper shoulders and things you're
probably you know using a fair amount of
energy to that part of the body
um but yeah totally I remember when I
had my first boxing fight and the coach
talked about the adrenaline dump that
you get
um where you know we would fit as
anything we'd done all these camps and
you're running stupid amounts of caves
and boxing stupid amounts of rounds and
you get through it find that training
and go home and you could do it all
again and then you step in the ring in
30 seconds in people can't hold their
hands up anymore yeah um but you know
understanding it now it's that stress
response cycle it's that fear
um the the build up of the event and the
event itself and then stepping in the
ring and fighting someone in front of
all these people when you're not used to
it uh and you're you're activating that
stress response in a big way and getting
that big adrenaline dump and then your
body's up regulating and and you're just
carrying that through so your athletic
performance isn't great in that moment
and funny looking back on it now like if
you could just remain calm by taking
conscious control of your breath and
really slowing your breathing down
pre-fight and really taking not saying
that's easy but really taking conscious
control to not let that stress response
cycle kick in into overdrive try and
balance and you know keep that
sympathetic uh that balance between
sympathetic comparison pathetic uh you
know then you'd probably hop in and put
what you would hop in and perform a hell
of a lot better physically yeah and you
see that with the fight for Life's a
good example of that you hear about
these guys
um training really hard getting in
really had good shape for I think it's
what two minute rounds of boxing and
straight away they're always naked
they've gone off their feet so it's
obviously a good example of it yeah it's
super fit guys like obviously so yeah it
all comes down to regulating that and
controlling that that response to stress
in real time yeah so if you were a young
young athlete again take your take you
back um sort of 15 years when you're an
incredibly good rugby player couldn't be
a good half back in uh opening for 19
combo batsman um what would you be doing
differently now with with the knowledge
that you know
oh I think I'd just pay I mean obviously
I just pay so much more attention to my
breath but just my state in general be
far more intentional about everything
that I did
um and yeah like I don't want to sound
like a broken record but understanding
that your ability to remain calm under
pressure and be creative really does
come down to your ability to control
your physiology uh and so you know I
would never have at 15 or 16 you've
probably paid any attention to breath at
all even if someone had told me yeah
um and
I think you know you used to go out and
you'd you know like you'd run and you'd
try and get yourself in as best shape as
you possibly could
um and well actually I didn't do much of
that when I was a teenager but you were
in incredibly good shape
um but you know you do all the basics
well and
um you never pay any attention to your
breathing at all and so uh if I could go
back uh I would pay way more attention
to it and I'd become incredibly
efficient with breathing because it's
going to help with my overall physical
um you know ability as an athlete but
it's also going to mean that I'm one of
those people who has control mentally
and the reality is if you can have
control mentally be someone who's always
calm and makes the right decisions at
the right times then you're going to go
a hell of a lot further right and I do I
do think like why why not more people
doing this like why is it not and every
day every team why it's not everyone got
like a breath coach Etc but and just
your point about being young probably
not listening to it but I even do
remember like at the Hurricanes we we
did have some breathing sessions and
preseasons but
um I felt like we sort of just took the
piss out of it because we didn't really
understand what he was doing it felt
like it was
um so sort of weird to be how how could
this make a difference like we're sort
of wasting time here we should be in the
gym we're doing running like while we're
blocking one nostril trying to breathe
for like 10 minutes in the gym it's like
just felt weird and we I don't felt like
we ever sold sold the picture or um
really understood why we're doing it
yeah and you know what our rugby culture
is like people are pretty quick
um to take the person out of things and
I was probably
um one of the worst I think I think
you're exactly right like you know
there's an explosion in breath work
um and performance breathing at the
moment
um you see guys like LeBron James is a
big advocate of it and you know when you
see guys like the bronze sitting um one
minute to go in the fourth quarter and a
timeout and instead of being in the team
huddle he's calming himself and and
light slow deep breathing and really
um just going into almost like a
meditative state so they can go out and
be sharp and that next minute make the
right plays uh you know when you've got
guys like that who are at the top of the
game as well understand your you know
best combat Athlete on the planet
arguably
um people like that the kind of proofs
in the pudding and I think there's an
explosion of it now but it hasn't been
accepted and I think the reason it
hasn't been accepted
um for a large part is purely because it
is very simple but it's been like when
you think of breath work traditionally
you think of a hippie sitting on a rock
meditating and and breathing and not
doing much you know it hasn't really
been associated with performance
um and so I think uh that's shifted
massively and it will continue to shift
in the coming years
um but I think you hit the nail on the
head like if you're just told to breathe
without an explanation of what's
actually going on then you don't know
why you're doing it and um you know at
the end of the day you go to the gym and
you train hard in the gym because you
know why and you followed certain plays
because you know the outcomes that
you're trying to achieve and
understanding why and understanding the
reason that you're doing something is
incredibly important so the
communication of it from coach to player
um and to individual athlete is you know
that's where it's at and I think
understanding there's so much that you
can do with the breath as well like
obviously it could be athletic
performance could be mental performance
it can be General Life and
um dealing with anxiety and mental
health it could be for health but
there's so many different ways you can
manipulate the breath to get different
outcomes and
I think the thing that's really
important is understanding the goals
really clearly of the team or the
individual player so that you can start
with something and have a focus
um and pick mental performance or pick
athletic performance or pick recovery
maybe initially
um and really focus on some simple
Frameworks around recovery even and then
through that you get into the practice
of breath work you start to see some of
the benefits and then you can expand on
it but I think if you go in and try and
do 50 different things at once without
any real understanding then it's
probably going to get lost so yeah I
think whoever's delivering the
breathwork training it's really
important that you understand the
environment that you understand the
coach so you understand
I guess the hierarchy of needs and
um because you know these guys are
already busy uh you know you go into a
professional environment you've already
got training after training after
training you've got all sorts of video
analysis you've got stuff on it's not
you want to add a whole bunch of stuff
to the schedule so
um you can't go in and override it's
about understanding what the team's
trying to achieve and where you can add
breath work to things that are already
in their existing protocols I think
that's a good way to do it and then with
the individual guys
um what are they personally really
trying to achieve with them and if you
can get on a level with them and really
connect and understand the player so
maybe some of the things that they're
trying to improve or things that are
holding them back then you can set
specific protocols around one or two
things and then work from there and I
know you're doing a little bit of work
with a couple of wattle ad guests um
Ricky riccatelli Anton Cigna Hugh Renton
to name a few like what what are these
guys sort of getting through at the
moment like were you seeing the biggest
fault in rugby players
um yeah so like Anton's come up for a
he's done a session haven't you come up
I've done a few with you and Ricky as
well
um and obviously like you said going
into a pre-season block at the moment um
but again it's different for every
individual like
um you know uh I won't go and talk about
what those guys individually are trying
to achieve necessarily but uh first and
foremost it's an understanding thing and
and yeah it's like opening their eyes to
it and going holy [ __ ] and getting the
buy-in I think that's the first thing
um and then you know looking at
instances where as soon as you explain
it they can see instances in their own
game or in their own life where they're
inefficient and their own weaknesses and
potentially how breathing is playing
into that and so
um you know these guys are hungry
professionals they want to get better
and they want to reach the top level so
um you know that pretty quick to admit
where they're trying to improve and and
point things out to you and then it's
just about making a plan together on
that
um it always starts with the basic stuff
I think for any athlete you're under so
much pressure you have so much training
load and then you've got life stress
coming at you as well so the biggest
problem for athletes is that they're in
a really sympathetic Street State a lot
of the time and for your entire career
you've been pushed up the top of a
mountain
um you've had people trainers coaches
pushing you hard workers how you make it
as an athlete you've got to outwork the
competition there's all these narratives
and biases and sport where it's all
about hard work and working yourself to
the ground and don't get me wrong all of
that stuff does attribute to being a
great athlete and a successful team
but no one's ever told these guys how to
come down off the mountain no one's ever
taught them to relax and like I say
being in a stress sympathetic state is
not necessarily a bad thing but if you
don't know how to get out of it if you
don't know how to switch it off if you
don't know how to balance that come back
to a parasympathena and it would come a
very problematic thing very quickly
um obviously you know little injuries
creeping up on your health things
creeping up on your mental health
creeping up on you
um if you're in a stressed overdrived
stress sympathetic State a lot of the
time throughout the day and you don't
know how to bring yourself down then
probably your sleep is going to be
impacted by that if you've got poor
breathing mechanics and you're breathing
badly during your sleep then your
sleep's gonna be affected anyway but if
you're in a stress State during the day
you're probably not going to sleep very
well which obviously is not going to
help with your recovery uh probably not
going to make you the sharpest the next
day in terms of your training and your
athletic output anyway so there's
there's cycles that athletes are stuck
in and a lot of the time the answer is
to try and work harder to eat out of it
and
um you know it's probably about being a
bit smarter in those moments and
understanding that balancing in the
nervous system down regulating
and you know looking after yourself
physically and mentally through breath
is a great tool and it's a great way to
probably you know
avoid things like silly little injuries
and and burnout and you know to make
sure that you're mentally in a good
place because I know there's a lot of
pressure as well and
um you know guys are guys are under the
pump publicly and you have a bad game
and you run out you know it's not just
in front of a couple of people it's in
front of hundreds of thousands or
millions of people
um social media is Pretty Tough so you
know there's all these stresses that are
thrown at professional athletes I don't
think people pay enough attention to it
we're starting to pay attention to
mental health and Sport now
um a bit more but probably not enough uh
and the reality is yeah I think the
first step with a lot of athletes is
simply to focus on recovery and focus on
bringing them back to her giving them a
talk so that they can relax and unwind
and balance the nervous system and find
a nice calm relaxed state for even 20
minutes a day so that they can get a
good sleep so that they can start to
recover and obviously that's good for
your mental health good for your
physical health it could be everything
else that's step one
um and then step two is looking at some
of the performance enhancing stuff
around your athletic ability and and
then obviously the performance under
pressure as well right you are an
absolute wizard could talk could talk to
you about breath work for I feel like
this could be a whole series there's so
much stuff that we could get through but
I haven't gone to the Instagram for
questions like I usually do I felt like
we probably don't need to hear your
Bender stories but there is one question
that I I do want to finish with it I
finish with every episode and it is uh
what's what would be the best advice you
have for a water listener mate that's a
hell of a question one piece of advice
I think it would be that your your
internal state is really all you have
like
um
when it comes down to it yeah you can
chase you know accomplishments and
money and and whatever else
um you can pride yourself on being the
hardest worker there's all these things
that we do in life but I think the
reality is like in life really all you
actually have to carry with you uh is
your internal State and so prioritizing
and paying attention to how you feel and
doing things
to create a blissful state in a state
where you're genuinely happy
you know we
are at peace is a worthwhile investment
of your time and I think previously
probably in my own life I've probably
pushed I've always been really outcome
driven and goal driven
um and I've like I say I you know
mentally tried to build myself into
someone who's bulletproof and Thrive and
adversity and all this type of stuff but
I don't know if I enjoyed the journey as
much back then and
um I think having found more balance
through breath work and learned to down
regulate myself and create like a really
nice Flow State and be able to control
my mindset a bit better my psychology
and a bit better
um not experience the underlying anxiety
and things like that I think looking
back I would just say that it's really
really important to pay attention to
your internal State and how you can
better it because that's the one thing
that's with you for your whole life
the best piece of advice yeah I've had I
don't know how many guests probably 160
I bet that was a unique piece of advice
I've never heard that before internal
state it was special and and so true
like um you're right like everyone's in
this goal to chase things for different
reasons and social media posts and stuff
like that but it really comes down to
how you feel yeah how you feel how happy
you are at the end of the day there's
multi-millionaires who commit suicide
there's professional athletes who commit
suicide there's people who battle
throughout their whole Lives who have
everything on the outside but don't have
their internal State and then there's
people who have their internal state in
a genuinely peaceful and happy who don't
have much else
who have a really good quality of life
and I think if you can be really
ambitious and driven and chase your
dreams and do all your stuff whilst
maintaining that and at least then
you're winning right so I love it what a
way to finish one of the greatest
podcasts yeah I knew I needed to get you
on to go through this and even even that
like I feel like I'm gonna have to
listen to that sort of three times to
comprehend some of those big words you
said but
um I I just I hope the people listening
you can feel like this breath work can
potentially give themselves some
benefits for whether they're
Professional Road Plaza or any sort of
Workforce like I know lawyers and things
like that yeah huge jobs with huge
amount of stress which this breath work
can be so beneficial for the man that's
right and yeah I mean I've got clients
who are lawyers for example and it's the
same thing right that extremely high
performance people they need to be sharp
they need to be on when they when
they're on but the flow-on effect of
being constantly on over a 10-year
period is a real big decline in mental
health physical health you know not so
good habits potentially struggle with
sleep and things like that and so you
know by just coming back and focusing on
that internal State and down regulating
and learning to bring yourself back you
can be more effective in your work and
have a better quality of life and yeah
it's not just for athletes mates for
anyone um like my life's dress we
improved on the back of it and I think
that's why I'm so passionate about it
you know I love the sports performance
aspect of it I love the performance
Under Pressure stuff but I think the
biggest thing is just a bit of quality
of life so appreciate you having me on
mate and I could probably sit here and
talk to you for another cup just feel
like we just got I just got cranking I
just got into it
I'm gonna have to listen to it and hear
what I just said but no I do appreciate
it mate and I know um yeah I always
appreciate you know having those with
you and I think you know you going into
a coaching role and stuff like that
you're interested in these types of
things uh you know will be extremely
beneficial to players and things like
that so thank you for embracing it and
uh having a conversation about it no
worries man I'll be breathing through my
nasals up in the coach's box staying
very careful next I'll be on you
but also super grateful for everything
you've done you've been a massive um
help to get this podcast up and running
I know you've run your own very
successful podcast and what you've
taught me throughout this process has
been priceless so um there's no no doubt
that you've helped Waterland get to
where it is uh today so I really
appreciate all the insights you've given
me along the journey and managed to pass
on some of the things that you learned
from on your mistakes which hopefully I
can pass on to anyone else who's also in
this game but um you really appreciate
what you've done for me and thanks for
coming on thanks mate I appreciate it
and yeah keep going with the body mate
it's awesome to see I actually had to
dust my mic off before I hopped on just
get the camera back out but you've
inspired me to get rolling again mate
it's been great to have a chat mate get
the potty vet going that's how I say
yeah we'll see maybe next year
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]